ننتقل مباشره الى قاعده الملك فيصل
البحريه في جده ومراسل العربيه هاني
الصيان هاني اهلا بك معنا ساعات مستمره
متواصله منذ الامس تبعناك مع وصول الباخره
النفطيه الصينيه وحتى الان كذلك ساعات
متسارعه لاستقبال رعايه اخرين حدثنا عن
الصوره الكلمه لك وصوره كذلك معك
نعم ووتيره العمل ووصول الاسطول من السفن
ووتيره العمل ايضا على الجسر الجوي تزايدت
امر مختلف عن اليومين الماضيين كانت سفينه
تبعتها ثلاث سفن وبعد ذلك ست سفن واليوم
نتحدث عن سبع سفن ما بين سفن تابعه للقوات
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه وبين ايضا
فرقاطات عسكريه لبعض الدول الاسيويه وكذلك
ايضا هناك في قاعده الملك عبد الله الجويه
وايضا هي في جده ايضا جسر جوي من مختلف
الطيران العسكري في جميع دول العالم تنقل
رعاياها او ايضا تقوم بجلب برعاياها من
السودان الى جده اذا مدينه جده اصبحت هي
المكان الامن الان بالنسبه لرعايه
الجنسيات المختلفه والبالغه عددهم والذين
وصلوا تحديدا الى جده من 69 جنسيه هذه
سفينه اخرى ولكنها سفينه جلاله الملك
الرياض التابعه للقوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه هي اليوم تقوم بنقل 200 شخص من
رعايه من جنسيات مختلفه تقوم بالوقوف الان
على الرصيف المعد لها وكذلك من قبل منسوبي
القوات البحريه الملكيه السعوديه والذين
يقومون الان بمد هذا الجسر الى
ظهر السفينه ليتم نزول رعايه الجنسيات
المختلفه والتي تم وصول هذه السفينه من
بورتسودان قبل قليل اذا هذه اللحظات
الاولى التي ترصدها كاميرا العربيه للوصول
سفينه جلاله الملك الرياض الى
الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في مدينه
جده هناك طبعا اعداد كبيره واضح جدا وايضا
بعض القنصليات
وكذلك بعض السفراء هم حاضرين هنا من اجل
استقبال رعاياها
سوف ما هي جنسيات
ما يقرب عن الاثنين والخمسين دبلوماسياتهم
تقريبا
نعم نحن نتحدث الان عن جنسيات معظمها من
اسيا نتحدث عن اندونيسيا تايلاند بعض
الدول الافريقيه وكذلك ايضا بعض الدول
الاوروبيه هم يحضرون على هذه السفينه وسوف
تتضح لنا الجنسيات بشكل ادق وتفصيل اكثر
عند نزول هؤلاء الرعايه دعينا نتحدث اليوم
عن صعوبه الامر الان في بورت سودان بحسب
حديث شهود عيان وكذلك ايضا بحسب الرعايه
السابقين والذين تم المقابله معهم سواء
هنا في الاسطول البحري هنا في قائده الملك
فيصل البحريه او كذلك في ميناء جده
الاسلامي او ايضا في قاعده الملك عبد الله
الجويه كانوا يتحدثون انه هناك المزيد من
الجنسيات المختلفه ولكن لا يجدون من يقوم
باجلاهم سواء من خروجهم من بورسودان الى
بلدانهم او ايضا على ظهر السفينه
شاهدناه ايضا هناك ان العديد من
خلال شهود عيان الرعايه ان هناك العديد
ممن قالوا ان الوضع متازم انسانيا وان
ايضا
كانوا يمكثون مده تجاوزت الاربعه ايام حتى
حصلوا على سفن تجربهم اليوم عندما كنا
نرصد او خلال الفتره الماضيه عندما كانت
شاشه العربيه ترصد السفن التي كانت تصل
الى ميناء جده الاسلامي او الى هنا في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه فكنا نشاهد
الفرقاطات العسكريه للدول المتنوعه كانت
فقط تنقل رعاياها باستثناء السفن السعوديه
تابع للقوات البحريه او كذلك الطيران
التابع للقوات الجويه الملكيه السعوديه
الذي كان ينقل الرعايه من جنسيات مختلفه
الامر الان عند وصولهم هناك مراحل متتابعه
هناك صعوبات ولكن تم ايضا تدليلها من قبل
الحكومه السعوديه خاصه ان معظم هؤلاء
الرعايه لا يملكون التاشيره الدخول التي
تمكنهم ايضا من المغادرات او مغادره
السعوديه الى بلدانهم فيمنح لهم تاشيره
طوارئ بشكل سريع حتى يتمكنون من الدخول
الى الاراضي السعوديه وكذلك مغادرتها خلال
اليومين القادمين بعد التنسيق ما سفراتهم
وقنصلياتهم الموجوده هنا في مدينه جده
عموما ما زلنا في الدقائق معدوده نقوم
بالدخول بشكل
ملفت من قبل المصور يلتقطنا بعض الصور
صحيح صحيح سنبقى مع هذه الصور وسننتظر
نزول من وصل الى قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه
في جده ممكن سؤال قد يتبادر لاذهان كثيرين
لماذا لا اتحدث عن بواخر السعوديه التي
تجري رعايا دول اخرى هذا مفهوم المملكه
العربيه السعوديه ببواخرها ستجلي الى جده
ستتجه الى جده ولكن هناك بواخر لدول اخرى
يعني لوغان هي باخره فرنسيه اختارت ان
ترسو في جده هناك اعتقد كذلك باخره
بريطانيه اختارت ان تتجه الى جده او ذكرني
ان كانت هناك دول اخرى دول اوروبيه اختارت
ان تتجه وترسوا في جده هل لانه جغرافيه
الميناء اقرب الى السودان ام لانه هناك
اجواء من المساعده والتامين حدثنا اكثر عن
هذه النقطه لو سمحت
كابتن فرقاء الفرقاطه الفرنسيه اندريه كنت
اساله هذا السؤال كان يحمل على متنه
سفينته العسكريه لورين اكثر من 400 شخص
وجميعهم من رايه الامم المتحده ونفس
السؤال الذي كنت اطرحه ايضا على السيد
الطيب ادم وهو ممثل الامم المتحده للطفوله
كنت اتحدث في البدايه مع السيد الطيب قلت
له كنا دائما ما نعلم ونعرف ان الامم
المتحده هي من تقوم باجلاء جميع الرعايه
الجنسيات في المناطق المنكوبه او الصراعات
هذه المره الان الفرقات الفرنسيه هي تقوم
بجلب او اجلاء رعاياكم والقدوم بهم الى
جده وكنت ايضا اسال السيد لوري السيد
اندريه كابتن فرقاطه لورين كنت اساله
لماذا لم يتجه هذا هؤلاء الرايه الى
بلدانهم طبعا هو كان جوابه ان هناك جنسيات
مختلفه
[موسيقى]
الرعايه الرعايه الدول المختلفه من او في
قاعده الملك فيصل البحريه في جده اود شكرا
جزيل الشكر هاني على كل ما تتفضل به في كل
مداخله من تفاصيل ومن تطورات من عندك شكرا
جزيلا
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات